these refugees from Afghanistan and
Pakistan are burning old railroad ties
to keep warm temperatures can drop to
minus 20 degrees Celsius here at night
the smoke burns their lungs and is
hazardous to their health but they don't
have a choice in the warehouses of a
former train station fresh air it's an
anomaly if you go inside and you have to
stay for 10 minutes so you will see and
you will feel that how we have to we are
staying here and if you stay just for 10
minutes so the tears from your eyes will
be a start and we're not we were just
waiting for the good news from the from
the Europe they are giving some to one
event over there in the in the border
there yes we were welcoming these people
since the Balkan route via Hungary and
Croatia was closed they are stuck here
some people began moving into the
warehouses in the summer across from the
train station the square here is now
known as Afghan Square during the week
Doctors Without Borders has a truck
parked here in case any emergency care
is needed for weeks the doctors have
been taking care of people with
frostbite bad coals and whatever else
comes up here is the usually skin
infections one half of them is skin
infection and though from that number
one third is the respiratory and the
other one the other problems doctors
here say the people will not survive
much longer in this illegal camp
especially if it stays so cold on
Tuesday the Serbian government moved
some 200 people mostly children and the
sick to an army base in the town of
obrenovic west of Belgrade the Serbian
government has started to move the
refugees from this horrifying place to
more stable places however they have no
interest for a long-term solution and
therefore these people are somehow
trapped in between and Serbia becomes
a buffer zone outside of the European
Union the United Nations is alarmed
without help from abroad especially from
the EU they feared the Serbs will not be
able to get the situation under control
we are very concerned about the people
living here since summer the number of
refugees and migrants in Serbia is
increased from two thousand to seven
over seven thousand now and although 80%
of them are sheltered quite well
sheltered by the government we still
have a number more than a thousand who
live in improvised shelters that like
these here until now the Serbian
government has tried to avoid images
like these getting out and if measures
aren't taken soon many fear the former
warehouses behind the old train station
could be forcibly cleared